[Musique]
m
nous sommes je le secteur de salazie sur
la départementale 48 au niveau de la
voile de la mariée qui se trouve juste
en roulant
[Musique]
nous avons pu su indices - terrain qui a
été fait il ya au moins deux enfants
donc on a fait
une purge sur ce côté là en
en élargissant le secteur
et vous voyez juste au fond là bas c'est
le secteur où
la route passer ses parts à bon et on a
fait des ennuis projeté pour soutenir la
falaise qui est juste en bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la route est aujourd'hui on peut dire
qu'elle est vraiment belle cette foule
de sa valdi et c'est quoi ça aussi je
pense qu'on veut
oui c'est bien sûr le secure mais ça va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]